okay so let's get started first I'd like
to thank you strangely for inviting me
to speak at this conference in this
amazing city of San Luis have you guys
been at the museum yesterday that was
that's the coolest museum I've ever been
at also cool thing is that the art you
know we can go on the table and you can
see some louise from there this is
amazing so my name is Jacob and I work
for Microsoft but I work for the new
Microsoft and this is the new an
official logo of the Microsoft the ninja
CAD on the unicorn and I work on the
Microsoft Azure management portal one of
the largest single page applications in
the world it's written in typescript and
it's actually I'm not sure how many
developers but I think number around 500
is pretty much what we have now and and
this app works even in Tesla this is my
my friend's Tesla car and you ran the
portal in a browser in Tesla I mean
that's that's pretty cool you know now
web is going like everywhere I have a
blog j-jizzy or nine dotnet I encourage
you guys to check it out and subscribe
i'm also on twitter my twitter handle is
jacob jiseok you can also find it on my
blog i'm developer but I also like
cycling I like movement so here I am and
Mount Evans this is the highest paved
road in North America 14,000 feet
elevation and the oxygen level at the at
the top is 50 percent of what we have
here so that that does pretty cool
experience
here's myself doing the shell to
Portland by Christ that biggest bike
race in America every year 10,000
cyclists are going from sale - Portland
doing 200 miles you can do it in one day
or two days so if you guys ever go to
Seattle you should check out the sale -
Portland it's very cool so let's talk
about JavaScript now you know there's
many frameworks coming out almost
probably probably right now somebody's
releasing on github then
the next one but you know the thing is
like every almost every year we have
some more popular and less popular like
last year it was angular this year react
seems to be dead and you know that the
biggest but what about next year so we
we don't know right because you'll have
to wait till next year but we can look
at the alpha version of the current
currently developed framework the
frameworks so I was pretty excited when
I first seen the angular 2 and you know
the idea of angular 2 is to take
advantage of web components this is what
the new web should be that you can
create a reusable components of the view
and JavaScript behind it and angular is
doing that I really liked it and and
then I was even more happy when Rob
Eisenberg the creator of Durendal
framework was pretty popular framework
around three years ago he joined the
angular team and they want to take the
best of the round out the best of
angular and create a new next-generation
framework so that was pretty cool but
after after a few months
Robin angular team didn't agree about
the vision and so he quit angular team
and he started doing his own framework
called Aurelia and I was a pretty sad
because I was like yeah so now you know
the angular guys will be doing the main
stuff you'll do some probably less
important framework angular a big big
thing but it won't be that good and I
thought that until I I've seen on his
blog so if you Bing with Google Rob
Eisenberg angular versus I really am and
here you can see the differences between
vision of these two frameworks and the
left hand side is the angular and the
right-hand side is Aurelia and I have
first seen that I was like that cannot
be true like you cannot do that and I
will and then I was thinking ok so
you're probably your view is probably
like 300 lines of code so then I scroll
down and I see the same here it's like
so simple
so I not really often check the alpha
version of frameworks but this time I
was like I need to at least check if
this can be true with this if I don't
have like another like file who is doing
all the stuff the angular guys are doing
here so I went to a Aurelia dot IO
website pretty nice clean website and
here if you click get started here's a
small tutorial who can get started but
the most important thing is here it's
the navigation skeleton project if I go
here I'll go to github and this is like
a starting point for you it's like file
new project for our area you can just
clone this so I'll do this I'll open my
console get bigger there's strange loop
and I'll just get clone this okay is so
fast so now I have this skeleton
navigation project our city here and I
will run npm install because this
project uses a lot of NPM packages in
order to make your development
experience better and actually let me
switch back to slides for a second so
our elia is written with ACMA script
seven which is the next next version of
JavaScript currently my script seven was
renamed to ACMA script 2016 because they
want to emphasize that now we want to do
very often new releases almost like
every year now that's called ACMA script
seven is just an alias of that and in
order to run a relay in current browsers
they are transpiling the ACMA script
seven to at my script five so now we
don't have this problem anymore that we
need to wait until the browser will
implement the standard we can start
using it today and by default area is
using bubble transpiler but you can also
use tracer or typescript event
transpiler in there under using NPM to
manage the modules and JSP em JSP M is
JavaScript package manager is it's like
Bower you guys
Neubauer how many people neubauer like
50% so so you use Bower to manage your
fronted packages and JSP M is the same
thing but it's like for Ahmed script 6
it's using system Jas which is built on
top of the night if Ahmed script 6
module loader so you can use Ahmed
script 6 modules using system Jas and
you don't have to use requirejs anymore
and by default they use gold for
automation for translation these
browsers sync plug-in to out to refresh
your website you are working on and run
tests so on so forth so let me open this
project so you see this npm is i will
take a while so i just opened a new
window here and I will go to strange
loop do skeleton project I open my
editor here I'm using the Visual Studio
code it's new lightweight ID created by
Microsoft
it's like sublime or atom and I like it
it have have trade-offs but what is cool
here you can run group tasks right from
there I don't need my console anymore
but first so this is you know what you
get by default from arena there's like a
lot of stuff right and you can see at
the package.json there's also a lot of
packages but most of them like for
example this is gold instrumentation so
you can ignore it here's the Karma
because they already are showing you how
you can write the test to your project
so you don't have to figuring out this
later on they already set it up for you
so you can start using it but for now
I'll just ignore all of this and I look
at the index.html file because this is
where all the magic is starting so and
here's nothing interesting I am just
importing some style sheets and here I
have a really app equals main and that
means that my app will be located in
mine JS file I can of course change it
to my app but for now I'll just leave
the default and this is a splash screen
this is what will be displayed when my
app is loading and Here I am importing
systemjs
like my script 6 module loader and
convict js
and in coming days I have a description
of my app so here I am saying I'm using
a bubble transpiler here I'm defying my
path where my JavaScript files will live
and and here I'm importing the areal a
bootstrapper which will start my app so
I have everything in source directory
and here's already the demo app but I
will just remove it from now and I'll
show you guys how we can create it from
scratch
so add new directory called source and
I'll add my mine JS file and here I need
to just implement one faction called
configure and this function have one
parameter and are called aurélia oh yeah
found is good enough and here in a in my
configure function I will say Aurelia
use standard configuration and I will
say Aurelia start and start we will
return me a promise and in my promise
I'm using ActionScript six arrow
function here in my promise I will say
set root and here I can provide my
default web component that will be
loaded with my app and I can specify the
name here like for example app but if I
don't do that by default I really will
assume that my starting component will
be app so I will just leave the default
I also have to export my function so it
will be visible for the entire app and
I'll add my first component our add app
dot HTML file and here I create create a
template I'll say hello
oh really yeah yeah and I'll create a
view model for my view called up J's and
here I'll create Ahmed script class so I
say export class app and for now I'll
just leave it empty because I want to
just display this static view so let's
see if my app is installed okay looks
like is it is so if my NPM modules
installed I also need to install my JSP
m
modules so say JSP m installed yes and
hopefully if everything will go fine
you know the problem of every line now
is that it's very early stage of alpha
so you know with every next release
there is a like a risk something will
not work so it pretty much happened but
you know once we get to at least better
I believe there's not a problem so for
now everything is working here so now I
will run gulp watch which will compile
for me transpile for me my JavaScript
files - Eckman script 6 and it will
launch the server with browser sync and
I can even grab this link from here and
I will place it to my browser and my app
is low that I have my default view hello
I really love it so I have my app
started but you know nothing nothing
interesting is going on so far now let
me actually a stop group here because I
don't I don't want this to be in console
I would like to run it here yes Karl so
if I say ctrl shift P and I say a run
task click enter and now vs code is
looking for my potentially gold file or
grunt file and it's looking for a task
and here you can see I have a list of
all my tasks so I want to run watch task
I say enter and it's opened a sort of
fake console in here for me and it will
run my app so I'll just leave it here
and I'll add something to my view so
instead of static text I'll add two
input tags and in this input tags I
would like to enter my first name my
last name and then concatenate the
string dynamically and just display it
so let's say I will add label here and I
will call it first name I also add label
here
and I call it last name and another
label called full name and sorry
and just TT tag I'll display my full
name here but so you know first I need
to create my variables on my view model
in order to be able to bind so I go to
my view model and I'll create a first
name I will set it to empty string by
default this is how we can create the
properties in icon script 6 class you
don't have to do crazy JavaScript
classes anymore and I will create the
last name as well also empty string and
I'll create a getter function called
full name and this function will just
concatenate my first name and last name
so say return and here I will use the
es6 template strings so this is this is
equivalent if I say this first name plus
quote plus this last name just the
syntax is better I think it's a more
clean so I have my view model I created
and now I need to bind it in the view
right so in angular you to put it in the
scope do some ng thing but here you know
on the input tag like in the native
input tag you just say value equals and
you add a string you want to set your
input tag to write so in Orillia you
also use value but you just say dot bind
and here you put the name of your
variable and I'll do the same for my
last name say value dot bind equals last
name and I want to display it I really I
use dollar curly brace for the template
it does a full name and this will
display my full name which is defined on
on my view model and you can see I am
not doing an explicit bindings
everything has happened
behind the scenes so let's see if this
works you can see my browser's
automatically refresh my browser sync so
say Jacob check ok probably you can see
I hope you can see it's automatically
refreshed in here ok so this is cool and
I can do a first name last name binding
but you know this is boring let me
create something good something more so
I would like to add a button create and
I'll I would like to get the values from
my fields and add the person to some
list and display this list dynamically
so but first you know it will be such a
shame if I'm using such a beautiful
framework but my view looks so crappy so
I will add the Twitter bootstrap which I
have also pre-installed here
github Twitter bootstrap I think CSS
yeah I'll just copy this path and add
this to my index say link tab control V
and I'll just remove the beginning of my
path because I just need relative path
okay so I have Twitter bootstrap I'll
make it look a little bit better now so
let's say I'll put a div container here
via Scout supports the Zen coding when
you know you can say div dot class name
this is pretty cool thing I think the
same I can say form dot form in line so
I want to have my fields in line I don't
need an action here for now I'll just
grab this and put in here because full
name won't be in my form anymore okay so
I have this I have that and I also say
that my input tags have class form
control I really like Twitter bootstrap
because you know I don't have to write
CSS anymore and this is really advantage
so let's see how this looks now oh so
much better
do it over for oh yeah that's what it
wasn't in line right
yeah and I would seem line cold thank
you guys
okay so let me add the button so say
button BT and BT and create I have two
classes I'll call it create and now I
would like to bind this to action I'll
add on my view model and I'll call this
action create and create I would like to
add my person to some list I'll say this
people that push and for simplicity I'll
just grab the full name I can also you
know add entire object and then manage
the first thing last thing but for
simplicity I just add the full name I
also need to init my people array to be
empty and I need to bind this to my form
so also pretty simple
I say click dot trigger equals create
you know this is cool because I'm
writing code like I speak English I said
click trigger create so this is already
done so let's see oh I need to also
display it somehow okay so I'll create
another container here say title people
and here I'll create a list and again as
I speak English
I will say Li repeat repeat dot 4 equals
person of people this is a Ahmed script
for off loop which iterates over the
values instead of keys as in for in loop
and here I would say just person and
this should display my array so let's
see how this is refreshed just make sure
say Jacob yet I will say create and it
pops up on my list I can also add Rob
Eisenberg say create so I have adding to
my list so now let's add also deleting
from my list so here I only the button
also our class BT and BT and delete make
it read and I also my need to action
saying click trigger equals delete and
you know I need to say what I want to
delete scientist I can pass my person
object or I can just pass the index and
you have it for free in Orillia I sank
Dollar Index it will give you the index
of element you're iterating over and
also here I need to say dollar parent
because Here I am in the loop I mean
scope of the person but I want to be in
scope of my view model so I need to go
to my parents cope and I need to add my
delete function here so I delete index
and then these people supplies I'm still
waiting until JavaScript will introduce
the delete add or something more
intuitive or removing from array and say
index 1 click Save Auto refresh so it
sees now Jake jet create and we click
delete it disappears I can add multiple
amounts I can delete them okay so I have
creating deleting to have a full crew
let me also add the editing so that I
would like to have a lot have an edit
button and if I click Edit I would like
my static text to become the input tag
where I can you know edit my name and
then I would like to change my edit
button into Save button to click Save
after I'm done editing so I'll go back
to my view and here how can I do that so
for example one thing I can do I can
create a new property called editing and
I'll set it to undefined by the default
and if I say edit element of index I'll
just say this editing is equal index
and then on my view I can figure out
which everything is fine I think so here
I can figure out which element is being
edited and I'll span tag on which I will
say show bind sorry bind equals so that
means that this pan tag will be shown
only if the condition inside here will
be satisfied and here I will say index
equals parent dot editing okay so this
is what I will be displaying when the
element is being edited and I would like
to have here the input tag and an input
tag I'll bind this to parent and I'll
create a temporary value which I'll call
it new value value and after I click
Edit I would like to set my current ID
to this temporary new value so let me do
it now so I said this editing and this
new value equals this people of index
okay so I have this and let me go back
here
so I also need to add a button which
will be almost like delete but with the
difference that it will be not it will
be just save so I say save and here I
say save and here I also say save so
this is what I will have when I'm
editing and also I I want to have
similar thing for not editing so I'll
just copy the span and change this to if
index is different than editing so that
means this element is not being edited
then just display me static text so I'll
save that and go back to my browser say
Jake jet create oops
let's see let it drunk oh I didn't add
the edit button sorry so here I need to
add the edit button as well actually
that need button should be out of this
because I won't always see it so my edit
button will be edit and edit okay save
see now st. Jakob jet create
okay I've added button click edit I can
edit it but I cannot save yet because I
didn't create a save function so let me
do it really quick I'll add save index
and here I will say this people of index
equals this new value so I get my
temporary value here and I also say this
editing equals undefined because I'm not
editing any anything anymore let's see
that Jake said create and edit my full
name save say that I can add another one
you know side of it and rub Eisenberg
click Save I can still do so you know
here I created the crude app writing 28
lines of JavaScript and and if you can
see here there is no framework specific
code at all this is just JavaScript in
here right
so everything this happened by
convention and it's taken care by
framework of course you can customize
all of this but I think this is pretty
cool that you know by default you don't
have to write my JavaScript at the
beginning you know in my V of course I
have a little bit framework template
specific things but this is a mess right
we cannot get get rid of that for now so
I have a very single page application
now I have some dynamic things but when
you create a new spa app you would like
to have multiple views right so you like
to have a router and you
cliegg and you can reload your views so
let's see how to do sing Aurelia so I'll
go back to my app and I will move all
this to new component I will call this
component per people-people dot HTML and
just place it here and the same with my
JavaScript I'll just copy this create
new file people dot yes paste it here
I'll just need to change my class name
to people and in my app HTML I'll remove
all of this I'll create a new tag router
view so here will be my view will be
displayed and here I'll also remove all
the methods now I'll just create the one
method called configure router
configurator and this method has two
parameters config and router and this
two will be injected by already a
dependency injection so I will save
router on my object in config I say
config dot map and here I will specify
the array of my routes
so my first route will be just
JavaScript object I'll say route and
I'll say empty string because that's
what my default route and I'll just need
to specify the module ID I'll call it
people okay so this should be enough -
and you see here I have all I had before
but in different files right so now I'd
like to add more views and I would like
to also add the menu you know to be
order to change it so in order to add
the menu I need to say here not true
because then this will be appearing in
my route and also will add a title which
we used for displaying the name of my
sub page I'll call it people and in the
view I'll just create a nav bar after
bar inverse some cool cause I think and
here also the inner fluid and here I
will create a list come yeah
thank you and here I will just iterate
over sorry
I will repeat we beat four equals R out
of router dot navigation and here I will
just display this I'll need to create an
anchor tag and again in order to bind my
link to anchor tag I'll just say href
not bind and here I would say route dot
H drive and here I'll display the name
of my route so I'll say you're out title
and I click Save see what we have and
you see not very pretty but it's here I
have my first route so let me add
another sub view so add another
component I'll call it about about dot
HTML here I'll just create a template
I'll say this is about page and I'll
also create a view model for it here's
the export class about I'll click Save
and I also need to add this to my route
I'll go back to my app I'll just copy
this paste it here and just change the
route to be about this to be about and
title to be also about and you know in
route what I can do here like I want to
specify the multiple routes for one
module so I can say I can say I have
Rey different routes here so first one
is empty this one will be called people
and then if I go to empty route dual
display module people if I go to people
are out it will also display me people
are out so let's save that let's go back
here I can see I mean about page Here I
am in the people page okay so I have a
single page app I can reload my views
but you know what you really want is
call your back-end right to get some
data and display it because that's what
we are usually doing right so in order
to do that I need to install our really
HTTP clients I'll go back to my console
and I will say JSP M install Aurelia
raelia HTTP client and I will create a
new component that will grab a list of
my repositories from github API because
I don't have to create an API then so
create a new component called github dot
HTML you created employ it in my
template I'll say h1 title my repos
Thank You I'll create a list in the list
I'll repeat that four equals repo of
repos
so the only thing now I have to do I
have to put all my repositories on this
repos property on on my view model sorry
oh yeah thank you wait okay and yeah all
right that should be fine make sure at
anchor tag and again I will bye to my H
Drive and in H Drive I think it was repo
dot HTML URL hope I'm not drunk and here
repo dot name so I'll display the name
link actually doesn't matter so now let
me create a view model for that I would
say github GS
here at export class github and here
I need to import a few modules and I'll
do it using Ahmed script module loading
I don't need to require this anymore
which is called so I say import inject
this is the module I'll be using to
inject my router into my class from
Orillia framework and also I'll import
HTTP client from aurélia HTTP client so
this package I just installed machine
let's see yeah it's installed and here
on class I'll say at inject HTTP client
and this will inject this as the first
parameter of my constructor so here I'll
create a constructor
Ahmed script six constructor and one
parameter I'll call it HTTP because the
name doesn't have to match this name
here and I'll say this HTTP equals HTTP
and actually you know I could call my
API in here my constructor but the
better thing to do is to create activate
method which is a pretty cool workaround
to delight a template rendering before I
call my a P I so I won't render my Dom
twice first time when it's empty and the
second time when my data will come so
inactivate will do that it's also here
this HTTP GET and if I remember
correctly those HTTP api github.com
slash users just my github login and
repos and here it'll return in a promise
and my promise I'll get the response and
so I want to save my response on this
repos property which I'm using in my
view but actually this response will be
a JSON and I want to convert my JSON to
JavaScript object so I'll just say
json.parse
this is Enoch my script 5 so this is
nothing new
and this should you grab my repos so
let's see oh I also have to add my
github route here so again I'll just
copy this route I say get github and
github I'll save this thank you can see
I have new route github I'll click get
Cup and nothing is happening that's not
good
sorry ok
oh yeah response ok lets you know ok
github ooh
403 that's no good ok so guys who's
using a github API you just destroy my
demo you know some free API and let's
say free API
ok that's not good
Twitter see Twitter's statuses can get
to your statuses let's see let's see my
statuses damn you guys know some API
Amazon API you say free API sample
if I do what I think so but I think I am
already logged in
yeah because yeah I think I had this
issue before when I was preparing the
stork course sorry now I think this is
issue with github that you know people
from this API do too many requests okay
so let me let me just skip it and you
guys just believe me that this will do
that call and damn were some okay sample
JSON data let's see here I have just an
example
okay here I have something how I can
okay let's let's move JSON data URL okay
that should be it
Jason test okay so here's something data
time okay
echo Jason okay let's do this do this
and yeah I'll convert my wrist bones I
have no idea what this will return one
and key so let's see I'll just display
it I say repo dot one let's see go back
to really on refresh
get up empty
okay sorry in the view model okay but
but but you know this is a response is
what is coming back from my API so
actually you know here what I can do
left 12 and let's analyze the network
traffic just why not so let's clear it
up and Here I am getting this Jason
repo of Freitas okay
oh yeah so I just need to do this you
say three plus one or maybe let's just
do this let's say console the log this
repos this should do the job right
and this here boom let's see console bit
HUP yeah there's object want to key
value yeah whatever
sorry for that I didn't predict that
they will allow the github API so you
know this is a pretty much all I have
you know so I have this small up not
many files
well I specifically like about that I'm
writing just JavaScript in here I'm not
writing a lot of framework specific code
and if you guys want to get sorry I want
to start from this guy if you guys want
to check out over Ilya go to I really a
dot IO and there is a tutorial there is
a very nice documentation there is also
the Provo site class building
applications with Aurelia by Scott Allen
and if you are not familiar with Ahmed
script six yet there's also great course
JavaScript fundamentals for es6 and also
you can check on bubble j as the diode
there's very cool overview of the
feature and like two sentences
explanation where is that for so thank
you very much and if you have any
questions please go ahead yep
I mean you know if you go to github and
you check our really other there is a
lot of contributors already ugh actually
our yeah where's the framework so here
you can see there is four thousand stars
and fourteen contributors and you know
this is the only you know this frame was
starting in December last year okay and
this is still alpha version so I think
it's still pretty good because as I
remember the old frameworks they didn't
have much contributors before the first
like actual release this is just alpha
stage so this is something new I think
like you should keep eye on it
don't go production yet but once it will
be released then I think that'll be you
know strong competitor to angular 2 and
you know you never know what's the best
like you know 2017 they'll be better
framework yes
yeah you can put it this way like you
know like like if you if you look here
you know the lot of stuff is done by
convention the advantages of that is
that you know you don't have to write
the stuff you have to write anyway the
disadvantage is that you know there are
some things going on the framework level
that you don't really know how they are
working but you know once you learn the
framework you know you can check it out
you can check even the code you know
this is just JavaScript anyway so you
know I I like it more because I like to
repeatedly write the same over and over
again so that so that was acting the
main disagreement between like Robin
angular 2 team yes
all right so the question is what is our
yet performance as far as I know
currently the next step they will be
doing developing this framework is
focusing on performance because like
usual you know performance is something
you leave at the end of development so
now they are working on that you know to
get out with a real matrix into way that
and some big project will be done with
our really away Frank Euler and then you
can really say because you know then
even the team that they can throw you
some matrix and high C you look at that
you know angular is this right oh really
is that fast right on then angular 2
team will give you some other matrix a
go this is this is Aurilia and we are
here right so it doesn't matter it
depends on your project and we just have
to wait for that but I think if they say
they will work on performance so they
keep this in mind ok thank you very much
you can find me later after my talk
thank you